[موسيقى]
انا مجرد ما وصلت للتقبل لا وضع ابني بلش
يعطيني نتائج
اذا بدك انا ناطرتها من سنين تعب سنين
عليه بلش يعطيني اياه لما وصلت لحالي من
التقبل انه خلص انا متقبلته كيف ما كان
وشو ما كان تقدم ما تقدم خلاص هيدا هو
ابني وبدي حبه متل ما هو وهيدا هو المفتاح
الذهبي قبلت بمحمود كما هو كاي ام ارادته
ان يرقد اليها لكن ما حدث كان العكس لم
تحقق فاتن احلامها بتخرج محمود من الجامعه
وبشهاده دراسات عليا محمود فتح لها بابا
الى عالمه فادهشها وانساها الحياه النمطيه
والصراع والتنافس ومسابقه الزمن في كل شيء
يعني انا كنت خاف انه انا يصير لي شي
ومحمود كيف بده ياكل ما هو ما بيعرف يقول
ياكل انا انا بدي اكل ما بقول انا عطشان
انا بروح بشربه بس انا الشيء اللي مقلقني
ولعطلت همه محمود طلع منه الحمد لله
تعتبري انه محمود هو اللي قام بالانجاز
الكبير ام فاتن
اكيد محمود
شفنا نحن بمجتمعنا اوكي
منكرم الام وبنشوف التعب بس للاسف
ما بنعرف قيمه التعب اللي هن بيتعبوا متل
ما نحن بنتعب هن بيتعبوا على حالهم يعني
منو شي سهل عليهم منو شي سهل عليهم لانه
هن
نحنا عم نكسر لهم طبيعتهم
لحتى اذا بدك انا بقول لك اكثر نحن عم
نشوههم عم نشوه لهم فطرتهم ليصيروا
يشبهونا